la commission européenne vient de sauver
la france d'une procédure de déficit
excessif alors qu'elle en menace
l'italie
pourtant comme l'italie de salvini la
france ne respecte pas ses engagements
européens en ne réduisant pas son
déficit structurel comme l'italie de
salvini
la france choisit de baisser les impôts
en aggravant les déficits comme l'italie
de salvini mme lafrance à un haut niveau
de chômage réel est structurel
les mêmes causes produisant les mêmes
effets comme l'italie de salvini vous
choisissez la dette au risque de faire
porter et je cite le fmi une menace
inquiétante sur notre pays
alors madame la ministre pensez-vous
avoir raison seul contre toutes les
institutions dont nous sommes membres
pensez vous que la bonne politique
économique soit celle de monsieur
salvini pour répandre la parole et à la
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre de
l'économie et des finances madame pas
dire une hache et vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs le terrain mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur bâches et je crois que le fmi à
apporter un large soutien à la stratégie
de réformes mises en oeuvre par la
france puisque vous souhaitez cette
institution il estimé en 2018 que la
france était de ce point de vue en pole
position dans la zone euro la mission
qui a conduite le fmi du 20 mai au 3
juin mentionne les points suivants
le fmi note que la refonte du code du
travail et de la fiscalité du capital
sont des réformes importantes et
qu'elles contribuent à la résilience de
l'économie
il précise que les mesures en faveur du
pouvoir d'achat ou un coût budgétaire et
qui va donc falloir réduire les dépenses
publiques pour appuyer les choix sociaux
fait cette année et je vous le rappelle
nous assumons parfaitement ses choix
sociaux et nous sommes parfaitement en
phase avec le fait qu'il faut faire des
économies de dépenses publiques et
d'ailleurs je crois que nous avançons
dans ce sens et vous le savez
parfaitement car aujourd'hui notre
déficit budgétaire à fin 2010 8 il est
de 2 5% en amélioration d'ailleurs par
rapport à la prévision ici
ce sera cette année supérieure à 3%
c'est que nous devons absorber des
décisions liées au cic au qui ont été
prises par ma mandature précédente
c'est factuel et c'est un coût non
structurelle je tenais à le préciser
s'agissant de la bête je veux également
vous renvoyez face à vos responsabilités
puisque l'augmentation la dette comme
vous le savez notamment due à la
réintégration de la dette de la sncf
et je ne crois pas qu'elle date de
l'année dernière alors oui il faut dire
que la situation économique de la france
progresse que le chômage a baissé de
manière significative puisqu'il est à
son plus bas depuis dix ans que plus
intéressant encore le taux d'emploi est
à son plus haut depuis 40 ans moi je
crois que cette politique économique
réussie et je suis fier de faire partie
de ce gouvernement
monsieur ben asher
voyez madame la ministre c'est pas très
gentil vis-à-vis de vos collègues
je suis obligé de vous le dire parce que
pour la dette de la sncf qui a été
réintégré dans la dette publique c'est
vrai que c'était une décision de l'âme
par lee au xxème siècle lorsqu'elle
était aux affaires
dans un autre gouvernement et que vous
êtes obligés d'en assumer ses
conséquences vous avez crié tout vos
cartouches budgétaire vous avez refusé
la réalité d'une dépense publique trop
forte
en renonçant par exemple aux 120 mille
suppressions d'emplois pourtant déjà
très modeste je vous le dis on ne peut
pas être de gauche sur la dépense et en
même temps de droite sur la recette
sinon c'est la dette pour nos enfants la
faillite en chantant pour notre pays
alors le nouveau monde sera-t-il en
vérité celui vous menacez de préparer
après une nouvelle crise économique
voulez-vous par ce genre de politique
que nous révélions italien merci